hello belief nation today I'm going to
share the seven signs that you were
destined to be a millionaire so get a
lot of questions a lot of people running
in and asking me I don't know if I'm if
I meant to be an entrepreneur I don't
know if I'm going to make a lot of money
how I'm not going to be success or not
and so to me there are seven key things
I'm going to break down for you guys
today I had to know if you are destined
to make a million dollars or plus as an
entrepreneur number one is that you're
self-aware and this comes both in terms
of your values and your strengths and
weaknesses so your values being this
comes down to your one word for me right
understanding the one thing that you
stand for who you are as human being
what the impact is that you want to make
on the world a lot of people live their
life by accident a lot of people live
their life as a reaction to other people
and what they want and their agendas as
opposed to making out an agenda for
yourself and when you get into business
a lot of times you partner up with
people who aren't the right people for
you because you don't have the
self-awareness to understand who you are
what the most important core value is to
you to then be able to surround several
people who are like-minded also on the
self-awareness is understanding your
strengths and weaknesses what are you
good at what are you one of the best
people in the world at and you look at
most entrepreneurs you know you're
spending eighty percent of your time
plus on things that you will never be
the best in the world at or never want
to be the best in the world that and so
that's a problem you're never going to
have massive success you're never going
to make a lot of money if you're
spending most your time on things that
you don't want to be great at
number two is that you take action the
signs of successful entrepreneurs are
they get an idea and then boom they're
off and running they take immediate
action even some kind of action some
small kind of action to be able to
realize their goal somehow where the
people who are just idea generators and
there's a lot of them we come up with a
ton of ideas and your creative geniuses
and you can fill a notebook full of
ideas but that's not going to help you
have a big impact that's not going to
help you make a lot of money that's not
going to help you change your lives if
you're just coming up with the ideas you
need to be able to execute and if you're
the kind of person who could take an
idea and then run with it and start
building momentum for it then it's much
more likely that you will have success
on your own as an entrepreneur if not
then you need to partner up with
somebody who is an executor partner up
with somebody who is not very creative
who can't come up with the ideas but
they can certainly go out and go take
action and that leads back to the first
point of self-awareness do you need to
have that business partner to help you
get to where you need to go
number three is you take responsibility
a sign of successful people is that they
accept responsibility for their life
they don't blame their surroundings they
don't blame their circumstances they
don't blame the government they don't
blame the currency you don't blame the
tax laws they don't blame other people
they don't blame their parents you don't
blame the school they went to they stop
blaming others and they accept that I am
responsible for my life and where I am
right now think about the conversations
that you have with your friends what do
you spend most of your time talking
about in general most people just start
talking about other people and they
complain and vent about the day that
they had and the life that they had and
they need a shoulder to cry on and
that's you consistently then it's going
to be hard for you to become a big
success because you're just blaming
other people and you just want to
complain complain complain we're the
most successful people are not massive
complainers right there may be some days
there is some bad moments but net-net
they are not huge complainers because
they take responsibility and
accountability for their life so
something negative that is happening to
you you figure out a way to overcome it
as soon as you decide that this is
happening because of me and not because
of any other force it's happening
because of me then you can start taking
action to change it and then you stop
complaining because you realize it's
under your control and you go off and
you start making those changes you need
to accept responsibility for your life
and where you are right now you are not
as successful as you want to be right
now and it's nobody's fault because of
you when you feel that it hurts but it's
the truth and you can start making
changes
number four you connect things together
a lot of the most creative ingenious
entrepreneurs didn't necessarily invent
things they just saw how things could
work from different industries and put
them together themselves Howard Schultz
who created Starbucks he went to Italy
on a vacation he saw how how Italy was a
mecca of coffee shops and how the coffee
shop was the center of life for Italians
and he just brought that to the North
American market was something that
already worked for decades in Italy that
didn't exist in North America and so he
brought it over and he saw the
opportunity to make that happen but he
didn't come up with this genius idea
himself it turned into a multi-billion
dollar business one of the biggest
brands in the world just because he saw
connection that other people didn't see
there's a easy way to be able to create
that muscle to force that creative
genius to come out a little bit more and
their exercise you can go through
I remember hearing one about when you're
trying to design something new pick a
random object and figure out how you can
apply it so example if you are trying to
design a new credit card and there's a
you know clear coke bottle next to you
say what can I learn from that coke
bottle to make my credit card better and
maybe you pull maybe the fact that it's
translucent rain like you could see
through it right translucent transparent
transparent what's translucent
transparent it's transparent you can see
through it maybe you make the first
transparent credit card and it's not
that you came up with this genius idea
you just took it from a coke bottle and
so there's things around in your
environment that you can pull from and
apply it to your business that nobody
else has done before
and that's what entrepreneurs are really
good at they see the connections that
other people don't
number five is you make learning a
priority successful entrepreneur
successful people risen the top of any
field they like to learn they like to
understand how things work they're
constantly investing in themselves they
set out in their routine where those
when they first wake up or at some point
during their day where they're investing
back into themselves or asking questions
or reading or watching videos or reading
books they're figuring new things out
you have to like to learn if you don't
like to learn you're never going to grow
right you're going to be constantly
stuck where you are right now and so
finding time when you're scheduled to
make sure that you are learning
something new every single day again
whether from a video a book TV show
whatever it is something that you're
bringing into your brain to help you
grow and stretch every single day that
knowledge you accumulate over time and
increase your power increase your value
so that you can bring that to the
business world have more of an impact
and make more money
number sixes you're not satisfied
successful people and successful
entrepreneurs they're not satisfied they
just they don't like what is currently
out there within their own products too
right I look at my youtube videos and
I'm not satisfied I'm extremely grateful
for how they've come out I'm extremely
grateful to happy for the audience and
you guys watching but I'm not satisfied
either I want it to be better it has to
grow more I wanted to have a deeper
impact more meaningful reach a wider
audience right we're never satisfied and
so that helps drive you to create more
things to have a bigger impact to have
more meaning and so when you look at
your stuff are you satisfied so yeah
that was really good and then stop
because as soon as you hit that plateau
as soon as you stop innovating and stop
creating something new that's when your
business starts to tank and so the
successful entrepreneurs are the ones
who are never satisfied with what
they've created
and number seven is you don't make money
your goal if you look at the people who
made the most money but the most success
as entrepreneurs who become not just
millionaires of multi billionaires money
was never their goal you look at Steve
Jobs he was a multi-millionaire in his
early 20s he could have done anything
that he wanted to do he could have
retired and traveled the world and had
the greatest life of all time but he
wanted to continue to work right like
the greatest life of all time for him
meant having more of an impact enjoying
the process and so if you make money
your only goal you'll never you'll never
reach it you never become the
millionaire because you don't enjoy the
process you don't you're not willing to
put in the work to be able to get there
where if you love what you're doing and
you're adding insane value and you're
having a massive impact then the money
comes as a byproduct I've added a lot of
value to your community and serving your
audience and so if you want to have
massive success as a millionaire then
don't make money your goal so that's my
take on the seven signs that you're
destined to be a millionaire I'd love to
know what you think of the video which
one was your favorite which one is most
applicable to you which one made you
think the most did I miss one you want
to add to the list leave it in the
comments below and I will join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Barry Ashcroft Barry thank
you so much for buying a copy of my book
it really means a lot to me those are
you watching if you want to change that
eye shadow in their future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon